♪ ♪
>> Laura: YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE
KNOWN THAT MARTIN LUTHER KING'S
DOCTORATE WAS IN THEOLOGY.
THE LEFT HAVE BEEN DILIGENTLY
SCRUBBING MUCH OF THE RELIGIOUS
LEFT DORMANT REFERENCES FROM HIS
HIS ACTIVISM ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION, MY
OLD FRIEND, RADIO PRODUCER,
CURRENTLY A COLUMNIST FOR
AND IN COLUMBIA, SOUTH CAROLINA,
LEE, YOU JUST WROTE ABOUT THIS
TODAY.
YOU BELIEVE THAT MUCH OF THE
KING LEGACY HAS BECOME
SECULARIZED.
HOW SO?
>> LISTEN TO THE MEDIA TALK
ABOUT KING.
AT DR. KING, DR. KING, DR. KING,
AND NOT REVERENT KING.
LISTEN TO THE SPEECHES THE
COURT.
THE SECULAR ONES.
I WOULD URGE YOUR AUDIENCE TO GO
TO GOOGLE AND TYPE IN "KNOCK AT
MIDNIGHT" SERMON.
IF A DEEPLY RELIGIOUS SERMON.
OR WHEN JESUS CALLS A MAN A FOOL
OR WHEN JESUS CALLS A MAN A FOO
FOOL.
INDEED THE SOURCE OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING'S INSPIRATION
WAS A BOOK CALLED THE BIBLE,
WHICH ARE QUOTED MORE THAN ANY
HUNDRED BOOKS COMBINED.
>> Laura: WE HAVE ACTUALLY A
GRAPHIC OF THE SPEECH WERE
TALKING ABOUT, THIS TERM AND YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
MORAL PRINCIPLES HAVE LOST THEIR
DISTINCTIVENESS.
FOR MODERN MAN, ABSOLUTE RIGHT
AND WRONG ARE A MATTER OF WHAT
THE MAJORITY IS DOING.
RIGHT AND WRONG ARE RELATIVE TO
LIKES AND DISLIKES AND THE
CUSTOMS OF A PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE UNCONSCIOUSLY APPLIED
EINSTEIN'S THEORY OF RELATIVITY,
WHICH PROPERLY DESCRIBE THE
PHYSICAL UNIVERSE TO THE MORAL
AND ETHICAL REALM.
THIS MENTALITY HAS BROUGHT A
TRAGIC BREAKDOWN OF MORAL
STANDARD IN THE MIDNIGHT OF
MORAL DEGENERATION DEEPENS.
ANTOINE, I LOVE THAT PASSAGE
THAT LEE PUT IN HIS COLUMN TODAY
THAT LEE PUT IN HIS COLUMN TODA
TODAY.
HE'S RIGHT.
YOU DON'T REALLY HEAR DR.
DR. KING TALKING ABOUT MORAL
RELATIVISM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
THINKING ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO
OUR COUNTRY TODAY.
BUT THAT WAS PRETTY AMAZING.
>> UNLESS I'M LIVING IN SOME
OTHER UNIVERSE THAT YOU GUYS ARE
NOT LIVING IN, THE REFERENCE TO
DR. KING THAT WE MAKE HERE IN
SOUTH CAROLINA IN PLACE A ZYGOTE
IS REVEREND
DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING BECAUSE
HE WAS A PASTOR BEFORE HE WAS
ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS.
IF YOU LOOK AT DR. KING'S BODY
OF WORK IN THE THINGS HE FOUGHT
FOR, JUSTICE AND EQUALITY AND
FIGHTING.
HE REALLY STOOD FOR WHAT THE
BIBLE TALKED ABOUT IN MATTHEW 25
AND 40, FIGHTING FOR THE LEAST
OF THESE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT NOW, I
DON'T THINK THAT DR. KING WOULD
BE PLEASED ABOUT THE CURRENT
PEOPLE OCCUPYING OUR GOVERNMENT
ON WHAT THEY FEEL AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
IF DR. KING WAS ABOUT EXPANDING
OUR RIGHT TO VOTE AT THE BALLOT
BOX.
HE WAS ABOUT HEALTH CARE FOR
EVERYONE.
HE WAS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE A FAIR AND BALANCED
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
HE WAS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
SITUATIONS.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE THAT GOING
YOU SAY PEOPLE ARE RECOGNIZING
KING'S RELIGIOUS LEGACY.
WE WERE REFERRED TO
DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.
>> Laura: IN A CHURCH THAT
MAKES SENSE.
I'M TALKING ON REGULAR MEDIA.
CNN'S TWEET.
HE'S AN ENVIRONMENTAL HERO.
HE WAS A SOCIALIST BEFORE IT WAS
COOL.
HE NEVER LET A POLITICAL
DISAGREEMENTS ARE NASTY.
MANY AMERICANS HAVE TURNED
MARTIN LUTHER KING INTO A SAFE
HOLIDAY MASCOT BUT SOME SAY
HE WAS A SOCIALIST BEFORE IT WAS
COOL.
LEE, WHAT ABOUT THAT?
>> IT WOULD BE INTERESTING OUT
TO LOOK AT WHAT
DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING AND
REVEREND KING WOULD THINK ABOUT
THE WORDS IN AMERICA AND EUROPE.
EVERY GOVERNMENT IN THE WORLD
WHERE THE GOVERNMENT LEADS FOR
THE LEFT THE CHURCHES GET
SMALLER.
THIS IS JUST A FACT.
WE KNOW IN THIS GREAT COUNTRY
THAT THE OUT OF WEDLOCK BIRTH
RATE IS 40%.
THAT'S WHITE, BLACK AND LATINO
COMBINED.
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHAT
REVEREND KING WOULD THINK ABOUT
THIS DISSOLUTION OF MARRIAGE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WORLD CALLING NFL ATHLETES WHO
PEACEFULLY PROTEST AS OBESE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WHAT
REVEREND KING WOULD TALK ABOUT
THE BUDGET THAT COMES OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT CUTS PROGRAMS
LIKE MEALS ON WHEELS.
>> Laura: YOU'RE MAKING THE
POINT OF THE SEGMENT, WHICH WAS
MARTIN LUTHER KING BASED HIS
PHILOSOPHY ON THE BIBLE AND WHEN
HE TALKED ABOUT MORAL
DEGENERATION, THAT WENT RIGHT TO
THE HEART OF WHAT LEE WAS JUST
SAYING.
THE DEGENERATION OF THE FAMILY.
ONCE THE FAMILY DISSOLVES, AS IT
HAS ACROSS ALL RACIAL LINES,
ESPECIALLY HARD-HIT OUR
AFRICAN-AMERICAN FAMILIES AND
ONCE THAT HAPPENS GOVERNMENT CAN
REALLY NOT SAVE YOU.
IT CAN'T SAVE YOU.
WE HAVE TO SAVE OURSELVES.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
GOVERNMENT CAN BE A BOOSTER FOR
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO PULL THEM
OUT OF CERTAIN SITUATIONS.
IT'S CALLED INVESTING WHERE WE
NEED TO BE.
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T DO THAT.
>> Laura: THIS YEAR IT'S
$5 TRILLION, WHAT HAS THAT
GOTTEN LESS?
50 YEARS.
LOOK AT THE K-12 EDUCATION IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Laura: ARGUE FOR SCHOOL OF
CHOICE?
>> I AM TOTALLY AGAINST SCHOOL
OF CHOICE BECAUSE IT WILL SEND
BACK TO A PLACE OF SEGREGATION.
WHAT I WANT TO DO IS INVEST
EQUALLY.
I WANT TO INVEST EQUALLY IN
SCHOOLS AND MAKING SURE THAT
SCHOOLS ARE FUNDED EVERYWHERE.
YOU CERTAINLY CAN'T BLAME TRUMP
FOR BALTIMORE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
MARTIN LUTHER KING WOULD THINK.
THAT'S PRETTY HARD TO DO.
THAT REALLY HURT A CERTAIN
SEGMENT OF THE POPULATION.
THAT'S WHAT I CAN BLAME TRUMP
FOR.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
BARACK OBAMA DID FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
BARACK OBAMA WAS PRESENT FOR
HARD-HIT COMMUNITIES THAT
MARTIN LUTHER KING DID CARE A
LOT ABOUT.
>> SO YOU ARE BLAMING
BARACK OBAMA?
>> Laura: IT WASN'T ON
DONALD TRUMP'S WATCH.
IT WAS ON A DEMOCRAT RUNNING
THOSE CITIES WHO ARE MORE